there's an old saying in in in show
business an adage among actors that one
of the hardest things to do in the world
is act drunk that it's an it's a real
challenge if you're an actor to pretend
you're drunk because people can sense
audiences can sense when someone's just
hamming it up and doing a cartoonish
version and when it's accurate on your
show you have to act hi I'm wondering if
that's the same kind of challenge well
there was a particular challenge in one
episode where where Ruth gets you know
she twists her ankle and so she really
overdoes it she has like a really potent
strain so I had to really you know go
there like you can't stop laughing right
and that is the that is probably the
best way to depict someone who is stoned
is stoned is just by giggling and
laughing well that's what I did yeah
[Laughter]
stoned sometimes I laugh till I can't
stop laughing try it with me now I'd be
your pusher okay but okay so what do you
want me to do you want to pretend I'm
stone yeah but but you have to laugh you
like hysterically okay all right so will
you start do is just start talking about
something like the weather what do we do
how do we get into it the weather is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you don't even really have to make any
sound ya see my what I was doing you're
right I was making noises also my guy
wasn't stoned my guy was having a
nervous breakdown that's how what that's
what I was doing and now that that were
you're just crying and laughing at the
same time yeah but I don't call that a
nervous breakdown yeah I call that the
happiest part of life
[Laughter]
you